Evan if you were unlimited could not
fail I am I am I on bro I and unlimited
in the next seven days Evan you ever
gonna do it like so that you can tell
you can you can fell what would you do I
don't know man I honestly I'll throw
curveball out and maybe it's not an seng
what you want but I don't really have
like I wish I could do this you know if
I get something to my head I just start
to do it you know I wanted to build a
house before I had the money to build a
house and I just drove by a plot of land
and bought the plot of land and figured
out a way like I don't have I wish I
could be here in five years I just start
doing it maybe that's why you know we
connected and we're attracted to each
other here but if I if I couldn't fail I
wouldn't be doing anything like I can't
fail right now like I'm already
unlimited things i'm doing i'm not going
to fail that if it's the fail it's
learning i'm moving on like I already
have embodied not failing you know like
and it's an it's an important mindset to
take in to whatever you're doing right
I'm writing a book right now and it's
about to launch to my publisher I want
it to be a business best seller right I
want to be one of the greatest business
books of all time and and that might
seem like egotistical and like it's not
trying to say I'm I'm this massive
genius but it impacts your mindset when
you're going to go write the book like
if I'm sitting down say i'm going to
write one of the greatest business books
of all time you approach it differently
then i'm gonna i'm going to write my
book i have a book in me right like
something you said everybody has a book
in them right like i said i write my
book well what's the difference even a
book that does insanely well in just
another book right so you you want to
bring that I think that's a challenge
for all your listeners to you bring the
unlimited path mindset to everything
that you do you already are unlimited
you can't fail now go take action do
something vam there we go you heard it
from Evan Evan Carmichael believe